feel free to raise your hand anytime in
the middle ask a
question disagree also it's
good
um all right
so I'm gonna start with some of the
challenges I see on my rer screen as
really
worth deserving uh
attention um to improve um her ability
to have impact in the world using gflow
Nets and derivatives that I'm thinking
about so as you know if you've played
with gflow Nets in fact if you play with
RL in
general that we can uh train these
systems these generative
policies when
the objects that we are constructing the
number of steps that are involved um is
small enough like 100ish number of steps
more or less is what we can do
reasonably well if we multiply by
10 yeah credit assignment becomes a
problem or something else that's our
guess C assignment is a
problem um
and I'll I'll talk about later of
applications where I'd like to
use
gonet in a way similar to uh what Trista
I assume talked about
regarding uh you know
generating theories of the world like
causal graphs and causal parameters
where the theory is just way too big for
the current algorithms that we have it's
not going to be something we can
generate in one
shot and so to expand the scope of
application of these methods I think
it's really worth first understanding is
it really a credit assignment issue and
maybe we can learn from what people in
RL have been
doing um or is it something
else um there's another practical reason
why having more than a few hundred steps
is not great because each step is
running a your own net you know
producing an output
so for most reasonable tasks you you
want to limit that uh if it's you know
um so it's just computational time um
now there's there's a path which I'm not
sure if this has been covered in the
workshop sorry I wasn't there all the
time I guess uh maybe in the continuous
um things there's
there's a way to generate a big
object which is not like the uh molecule
generation one little bit at a time
given the previous ones or like what
aggressive llms and so on but generate
everything in one
shot badly and then modify it and then
modify it and then modify it like an
mcmc for
example and in principle you could
generate much bigger
objects in this way
um so by the way there's a computational
reason for doing it this way so imagine
you want to generate a parameter Vector
like if you're beijan and you
got 100 million parameters you don't
want to do 100 million feet for steps on
the new net right it's not even besides
the the credit assignment problem it's
just not
reasonable um but you can certainly
generate a vector of size 100 million I
think that's something computers today
can do um and
then modified 100 times right so now
that becomes something because gpus
paralyze we can have a lot of
outputs but we can't really run
sequentially 100 times or a thousand or
a million times that's it's going to be
too
much so there is some ongoing work
that's like that it's the same style of
computation you find in diffusion den
noising and things things like that and
mcmc um I think we need to push that
boundary and see how far we can go with
that and really try to scale it
up um there's
another less clear thread that we'll
come back in another slide um something
that's been explored a lot in
reinforcement learning which maybe you
can also we can also learn from that's
called haral reinforcement
learning um so so okay we can't generate
a huge
object easily so now it's back to the
credit assignment um but maybe we can
like break down the problem into smaller
problems kind of divide and conquer so
people in haral arel think about options
and skills and you know a high level
plan so we decompose the problem into re
reusable pieces um so I I think this is
this is really worth thinking about and
I'll come back to that um the other big
area which I think
uh is worth spending more time on is
training
efficiency
and the tricks we're currently using
now we kind of figured out pretty
quickly in the first few months of
playing with G flet and there's been a
lot of work trying to improve on that
and I think
we only made marginal
improvements so
so there there may be several aspects to
this but one that I find
particularly mind bugling is also
something that we can take inspiration
from the work in uh reinforcement
learning
exploration so you know in RL we're
asking where should the agent go in
order to collect useful information
given that it can't go everywhere
information that will help it later to
um to get high
rewards and so in the case of gfl Nets
we have this freedom of choosing the uh
training distribution the behavior
distribution the uh the behavior
policy how do we pick those training
trajectories so we you know we we have
tricks we um we can use some data we can
use greedy uh exploration tempering
prioritize replay maybe others I didn't
think of um but but I think there's a
lot of potential
there or maybe it's like very hard and I
don't know but but it could really help
to scale
up U because sometimes if you've played
G
Nets we think we have a well defined
problem we you know turn the
crank and
H the optimization doesn't work like
we're we're stuck in subop Solutions we
don't find the high reward
configurations trajectories and so on so
so it's an optimization problem and it's
an optimization problem in the case of G
which we can think of as an exploration
problem um so when we think about it as
an exploration problem
my
geometric uh intuition is
that uh a lot of it is about
generalization so if you think about
what we're trying to do is guess where
potentially uh good modes like high
reward regions would be without having
to try everything it's the exploration
problem right right where is there high
reward in a very high dimensional
space
and it's hopeless if you just do like
some local search I mean we should do it
and there's some nice recent work um
combining mcmc local search with gonet
for example but it doesn't solve like
the bigger
problem um and so maybe the solution
isn't going to be
with the auto Loop or the you know
tricks generic tricks maybe the solution
is going to be as usual in machine
learning how do we get better
generalization inductive
biases right so we kind of do something
magical with the architecture we invent
attention and
suddenly you got a revolution on your
hand um so that's one one thing that I
think is worth uh pushing maybe maybe
exploiting the particulars of the
task or fairly General ideas like I was
talking about you
know Notions of abstraction and uh and
and reusable components and things like
that so which which is all about
generalization like how do we we're
trying
to um guess modes from a few mode so
it's a difficult
journalized um who talked yesterday uh
explored but we we
haven't we haven't find found yet a
satisfying solution I think he has a
paper but it's
exploiting the uncertain
about what the new net has learned so if
you know we're trying to get the loss
low
everywhere
and
um there are there may be regions where
the new net can generalize with
confidence that okay this should be low
reward place or this should be a high
reward
place um mostly we need to explore or in
regions of low certainty where in other
words like if you were a basian you
would like to go so you we may want to
think about the training problem in
gflow Nets like an active learning
problem because we we are able to query
the reward function it's not like a
usual learning problem with a fixed data
set and we're trying to minimize a loss
on those points it's very different it's
much more like an active learning
problem
and maybe we should be thinking about
training methods for g-l Nets that are
inspired by the ideas in active learning
and and one of the central ideas maybe
Mar presented is um estimating
uncertainty and then direct your
attention to the places of high
uncertainty so how to do
that isn't trivial like simple things
we've
tried was it's not that easy and then
one reason why it's not trivial is
that
um the uncertainty that the new net has
about some particular
configuration is going to
change the moment you update it with
some
example right so you can't have like a
separate process that estimates
uncertainty um we tried things like this
with salm and others um last year
um it's got to be something built in
your GF net that it both estimates flows
policies and their uncertainty so
that you know you don't need you don't
have this like non-stationary issue that
um otherwise you would
get
okay any question up to now because I'm
going to kind of change um sort of mood
a little
bit you sure there's so you're talking
about the uncertainty in the policy
right sorry you're talking about the
uncertainty in the policies right
yes the uncertainty in the policy or the
flows or whatever your parameterization
is yeah because you could also leverage
the uncertainty in the reward are are
you assuming the reward is perfect no so
here I'm assuming the reward is
known if so this is a different question
like if you're also learning the reward
function and that's the
usual um Active Learning B optimization
you know g flet style
thing um but now I'm talking about a
different thing where we want to improve
training of the gonet and we want
uncertainty about what the gonet has
learned so I have a question about the
generalization did you get closer to the
microphone or speak louder yeah uh so I
have a question about the generalization
part do you think it's related to
picking the training trajectories or
it's more related to choosing the state
space and ction space of your gonet that
will help you generalize because maybe
there's some yeah and the architecture
so in the gfet community we tend to
think oh okay so we have all of this G
machinery and plug in your architecture
and don't worry about it but I'm saying
well maybe it does
matter I mean not only the architecture
but even the state space yeah yeah the
state space the action space all of
this is you know involves choices that
could have a huge effect on how easy or
hard it's going to be to optimize our
objective yeah by the way it's the
normal thing in machine
learning I was just going to comment
about the uncertainty estimation that
somehow the information we have about
the forward trajectories and the forward
policy and the backward policy and how
inconsistent they are with each other
that's already some kind of
built-in uh to estimate UNC
so yeah wondering but they could be
consistent and
uncertain true then you go yeah so yeah
I think I think what you're saying is
like an extra clue but it's not
sufficient yeah yeah no no it's to
com okay so let me move
on um I'm going to now talk about Vasan
stuff before before I talk about beian
stuff I'm going to talk about the
problem with not being
beian
um by the way before G flet came into
like my mental landscape I used to think
that basan machine learning was nice in
theory but impossible in practice and
I've changed my
mind and so much so that now people
think I'm a beian I've always been it's
just I thought oh this is like oh nice
thank you but
um yeah I didn't see how we could mesh
that with NE Nets and and what you
know but but but now I see and we we
have several papers going in that
direction so so yeah what's the problem
with maximum L cute um in practice we we
know with llms for example we get
hallucinations we get are are trained
models to be confidently wrong and
that's bad really
bad and potentially really
dangerous um and when we
consider
uh a model that is then being used as
like a reward function or um in
reinforcement learning as World model
and then we're going to optimize some
policy on that then things get even
worse because the policy is going
to optimize over that confidently wrong
model and it's going to be sure that it
has found a way to make a lot of
money but it's going to be a
fantasy and yeah when it's too good to
be true don't trust
it so so what can we do about this I'm
going to try to argue that we can be
basan and that gonet style methods going
to help us
um deal with that and then later I'll
talk about some of the challenges which
are related to what I already
introduced okay so
again why being um beian is important
and I'm going to highlight the safety
aspect of
it and you know
safety introduces the aspect that some
of the actions that your AI system can
take can have catastrophic
outcomes how do you avoid that so you
have to be conservative in some way and
if you're going to be conservative you
need to have a notion of what can go
wrong even if you're not
sure okay so let's consider this like
really simple scenario you got an AI
it's in front of two doors left door
right door you have to choose go left go
right
binary and it's seen data based on that
data there are two theories that are
compatible with the data that it could
choose and if it's going to do maximum
like you is basically going to pick one
of them completely arbitrarily so if you
think about neural Nets depending on how
you initialize it
or the particular biases that exist in a
model but us you know um you might find
one Theory or the other
Theory by the way one way of being
basian in a cheap way is to train
multiple neural Nets with different
initial weights and and then that that
gives you a sort of cheap ban solution
but but but you know let's uh let's see
here our robot um can go left or right
and the first the the so you know in the
bubbles there um the theory on the left
says if you go left you die that's the
catastrophic outcome if you go right you
get some
cake the other Theory says if you go
left you get some cake if you go right
nothing good nothing
bad okay so what happens if you pick the
you know one of the theories maximum
lude um we don't know which one is
correct so let's say it's
50% and um if you're not lucky you pick
the wrong one so that's
25% um so let's say that uh the correct
one is the one where you die if you go
left and you pick the wrong
one well you die because you think you
get cake and you're gonna die so not
good
um if you're basian the idea of being
basian you know all this B
sounds complicated but really it's super
simple it's just keep track of all the
theories and act accordingly in a
rational
way so keep track of the theories you
just by inspection you can say oh I
don't want to go left just in case right
go
right so so that's it and you don't die
you get 50% cake 50% nothing pretty
good all right so that's easy when you
have only two theories but what if you
got an exponential number of theories
and how do you do that you know in a
non-toy
setting
um so so if I say that a theory is a
your net it sounds like it's not
feasible unless there's just 10
theories but if if there's an
exponential number of theories because
there are many combinations of things
that could be you know right and
wrong um maintaining a billion y Nets is
not going to cut it
practically so how could you do that uh
in the past people have been handling
the the
beijan machine learning
question um
making abusive assumptions that which in
the end mean that those systems didn't
scale to complicated tasks so making
very strong assumptions about the
underlying distribution that make it
possible to
do the basian calculations these there's
going to be like sums and integrals that
are intractable in general but sometimes
you can do it analytically and like
linear regression for example um but of
course then things are not linear and
you know then your model doesn't
work
um right
so so here's an important
message even though the exact dat
posterior is generally
intractable in principle we could use on
your net to represent the distribution
over those
theories right so so instead of
maintaining a billion theories let's say
you've got one your
net that is not representing a theory
but it's a generative model that if you
sample from it gives you a
theory okay so you don't actually
enumerate theories you just have a
machine that can sample one of the
theories um and I'm going to try to
explain that if you had a gonet that
would do
that um you can basically solve the
problem but there's something
um interesting
here if you've kept track
of all the excitement in AI in the last
uh few months and
years um
we can train really really large Neal
Nets and they can learn really really
complicated distributions right this a
whole point about the llms and and
Frontier ey
systems and in fact if you look at the
gonet
objectives with enough compute like a
large enough neur net and training long
enough you can get arbitrarily close to
a objective value of
zero I mean earlier I said it's hard to
train and so on but but it's just a
matter of how much compute it's not
about generalization I mean
generalization will allow you to train
faster but but in principle it's just a
matter of
compute um and so you know maybe there's
a way that we can actually approximate
these posteriors that are interactable
in fact every day we use NE Nets many
applications to compute distributions
that are otherwise you know intractable
we we approximate them right so it's
just seeing the same thing um okay so
how would you do
that
[Music]
um right so remember that the G flets
learn a generative model over some
objects so here the objects would be the
theories that the agent has in its mind
and it could sample one of those
theories one at a time and
and the objective functions and you know
the training objectives we have many but
bottom line they all have the property
that if you minimize them then the gflow
net will sample proportionally to the
reward function so how could we use that
to get a basan posterior well it's very
very simple and easy it's just one line
in the
bottom so let's say we want to get what
is the Bas posterior we want we want we
want two things but the the main one is
p of Theory given
data so theory is
like a hypothesis about how the world
works or some something you know the a
model uh whatever could be parameters
but it doesn't have to be could be a
program that's the way I like to think
about
it so so we got we would like to have a
new net that samples a program that's a
theory that that explains your data and
we'd like to pick the theory that is the
most likely no we don't want that we
want a sample of theory proportionally
to its posterior okay so that's what we
would like and if you remember base rule
which hopefully you would
do um in order to get a sample from that
posterior we can use as a reward
function the thing on the left which is
the prior P of theta times the likud P
of data given
Theory and the reward is actually
something that we can compute there so
the prior might be something
like two to the minus length of the of
the
theory we can choose prior in many ways
but that's just one that's has a lot of
nice theoretical properties anyway it's
easy to
compute the likud is like your normal
like maximum likud objective right you
would have loged likelihood usually so
it's something we can compute and we can
even easily show that you can get away
with using a mini batch of data rather
than looking at the whole data set
because data here is the whole data set
if your data set has a billion things
well you know um you you you don't want
to have to do a pass for each update of
your gonet you don't want to have to do
a billion computation you know or at
least you know a billion examples but it
turns out it's fairly easy to get a
stochastic version of the
reward um using a mini batch detail but
point is in principle we can train G FL
Nets so that they will sample over these
theories if the theories are small
enough right because remember what I
said at the
beginning um now actually what you want
is a little bit more than that but it
turns out ginet can do that for you we
want two things we want a sample over
theories so that's P of theory given
data here data is D sorry
um but like what do I do with a theory
actually what you want in practice for
many problems is is answering a question
also known as inference so let's say
think about an llm like X is the
question and Y is the
answer so what you want is p of you want
another NE
met that learns to sample answers why
given question questions X and given the
data
set that's the thing you want that you
know you've got a data set somebody asks
you a question and you want the answer
that's like the rational question that
you really are
after and you see that you can write it
as the you know marginalization where
you sum over all the theories well
that's where the other guy that samples
theories becomes
useful now if I had to run you know to
estimate that sum by monteal by sampling
from the other network that generates
theories and then cranking it wouldn't
really work I mean it would be very
expensive because at runtime you would
have to call
this um and it would be it would be a
pain so there is another
way which is we jointly learn to sample
and to marginalize so we can like train
one g-l Nets that does two things at the
same time and if you followed my little
uh present presentation yesterday
morning I showed how you can do that
like like the if you think about the
initial State flow or the which is the Z
or the partition function it
is an intractable sum just like
this um and so you know we train the G
we get both the the marginalization
function and we get the simpler of
theta so so in terms of like the
mathematical principles we know how to
do that both of these
operations the only little problem is
Theta is way too big for any like for
most problems of
interest
uh okay now sorry yeah yeah yeah go
ahead so for your for your second line
for marginalization your P Thea not only
depends on D but it depends on your new
input so does that mean you need to
train a g flet for every input that you
for every new input that you want to e
no no you could condition on X you can
condition on so I I didn't do all the
details but instead of the one so think
of d as
a a set of XY pairs actually what you
need is you condition on that plus an
extra
X um and you can you can get it there's
like a simple way to get
both yeah don't worry about
it
all
right so as some of you know I've been
worried
about um misuse of AI and loss of
control of AI this
year and I've been thinking a lot about
from a technical AI point of view what
can we
do
and I've come to the conclusion that
what would be really great
to make sure we can build AI that are
not
dangerous
is if we could train an AI that
understands the world and human
psychology well
enough but also understands its own
limitations of knowledge epistemic
uncertainty so in other words it's
ban and anytime a machine like an AI
another AI or maybe um um proposes to
perform an action we would call this
which I call them AI scientists because
it's basically a world model so it it it
has
sorry what's going on you know it can do
these modalization so it can answer
questions about harm that may follow
given a particular particular action in
particular State and
so yeah if we if we were able to train
such um a specialized
AI well you know in general it wouldn't
be specialized it would be knowing a lot
of stuff in order to be able to answer
these questions we could use it to
reject actions that are not
safe um and by the way that's very
different from the way people are
thinking about safety these
days um and and and
more reassuring because I'm not
reassured by the way people are doing it
right now they're like spot checking
okay let's try this let's see the if the
AI you know gives a recipe for building
a bomb to bad
guys all right but there's so many ways
you could query these systems it's hard
to be sure that nothing bad will happen
and in fact as soon as these llms are
put out somebody finds a way to destroy
all the safety protections
but if we had this evasion thing we
could
get
quantitative probabilistic safety
guarantees which I think would be a lot
safer the day when we
reach machines that are smarter than us
I you know there's I wouldn't trust just
some kind of oh let's try it and see if
it works I would rather have some sort
of guarantees that it's not going to
turn against
people
okay so now let me go back to this
question of training an AI scientist as
I said in principle we have the math for
it we just don't have the algorithms to
scale at that level of understanding of
the world uh comparable to what you find
in chat GPT and things like this so what
what um what could we do well I want to
go back to this question of breaking the
task of um of training and understand
and building an understanding of the
world into smaller pieces like this
divide and
concer um so I've always had huge
inspiration in my career from Human
intelligence it's been an amazing
success how do humans manage very
complicated theories of how the world
Works do we like spit out in our mind a
theory of every
thing
no we have like little pieces that are
relevant to the current situation or
some imagined
contexts and somehow it's like a
patchwork of how the world works that is
more or less consistent
but if we think a lot about all of these
things we manage to so think about all
the papers that scientists write they're
like each each of them is talking about
a little piece of reality theories about
things and evidence that it might be a
good theory a piece of theory
right
um so yeah so I think this is this is
this is a direction I'd like to
explore
um there's another analogy that I find
inspiring which is how we do pro
programming and how we do mathematics
and there are a lot of connections here
so programming mathematics scientific
theories presumably you know we can have
done all of three here people in this
room they all have this
Patchwork kind of property but also they
all also have this notion that we can
Define little pieces
like a definition of a function in
programming or a LMA in
mathematics that can be reused in many
ways in order to come up if we were to
unfold it completely with a
theory that's fairly small but explains
a lot of thing which is remember oam's
razor and like machine learning 101
so um yeah I think that solving this
problem might give us answers to
building AI for science for mathematics
for programming they're all connected in
a deep
way right I don't want
to yeah so the last bit I want to
mention about
safety uh if we were to apply these
ideas I mean if we were to come up with
algorithms that would do all these
things
um so going back to the safety
question current approaches to building
Frontier is systems rely on
reinforcement
learning and there's a fundamental like
issue that I mentioned you know too good
to be true and we're optimizing these
systems so that they might find fantasy
answers and in fact there's a lot of
analysis suggesting that as we make as
we increase the compute
power as we make these neural Nets
bigger as we train them longer we get
less and less safety so that's why a lot
of people right now are trying
to figure out you know do they know how
to do X because if they do then that's
may be
dangerous and even there are methods
called unlearning where Okay so we've
got we've trained an llm but it it knows
how to make
bombs can we like remove that from its
knowledge so all sorts of
like um ways to uh address the safety
problem but it would be nice if
instead uh we were in a scenario where
the more uh compute we put in our neural
net the more the longer we train it the
bigger we make it the safer we get and
and I have this conjecture that you know
under there some
hypothesis um the sort of approach that
I've talked about if we can find
efficient algorithms that can scale um
would have exactly this probability
because the more we would train our our
neural net maybe G Net style the more it
would approach the beig and posterior
and the be and posterior would be sort
of safe by construction uh because when
it doesn't know if something can be
harmful if you know it would basically
not do that action it would it would say
well you know there's a chance this
could be harmful so let's not do
it
[Music]
um yeah I think I'll stop
here you
sure um so this is this is not well
phrased but I want to discuss um the um
non-stationarity of that distribution of
human preferences oh
yeah you mean in time yeah I mean we
yeah yeah yeah it's it's a big goal
right um we can start with trying to
understand a single human but ultimately
for an AI to be safe it has
to build a model possibly very uncertain
where it knows UNC its own uncertainty
about all humans or at least all humans
that could be you know benefiting or
harmed by its actions so it's a tall
order but in a way we are doing it right
so I I don't know what most of you think
but I I have some general idea and
including some uncertainty because I
know that there are variations between
people and when I get to know a person I
know what their preferences are and when
we're not sure because we don't know
that person we behave accordingly right
this is what we would expect from aasian
AI yeah this is actually the the
connection to the second thought which
is we're going to have also to decide
how much detail we want to give that uh
AI like if it's going to have to have an
impact on on me as an individual then I
guess as you just said you're gonna have
to provide information if you want about
yourself but if you're going to have if
this is going to be a if the action of
the agent that's wearing the scientist
is going to be more Global then you have
to have a representation of that Society
or that group yeah yeah the only way
eventually you know when we we reach AI
that are deployed in the world um is
that they they have a pretty good
understanding of society psychology and
all the diversity of cultures and people
yes there's no other way
around I'm also curious about this
question of building the like beijan
posterior of human
preferences and it seems to me that in
general in beian when we do ban
inference we treat data points kind of
simil
but when I think that's a choice we can
make yeah okay but yeah I'm curious in
this specific situation because maybe
for some questions in general um like
you may need some expert knowledge to
estimate their harm let's say of some
action yes and very few maybe people in
the world can give you precise answer
and general population would not know so
I'm curious how how we're going to treat
this situations okay so one thing I
didn't talk about
is in order for the kind of approach I
mentioned to
work and to provide any kind of
guarantee it it will need to have
figured
out pretty much all the ways that humans
theorize about themselves and about how
the world works and um and you know
moral
questions um
so yeah I'm not saying this is something
we can build tomorrow but if if you
think right now we're trying to figure
out the algorithms that would could lead
us there and we could start small but
yeah ultimately if we want to build AI
systems that are very powerful and maybe
smarter than humans we want to really
make sure that they're going to behave
in a way
that is uh is consistent with with uh
all of the information available to the
human and by the way if it it doesn't
know but it thinks Some Humans might
have useful answers then it could go and
ask them in fact one of the original
Works um coming up with similar ideas as
in Stuart Russell's book 2019 human
compatible and there the focus he puts
and a ne's paper that had in 2016 on
this is the relationship between the
human and the AI so when the AI doesn't
know because it's it's basian it has
uncertainty it can ask the
human uh you know what do you think
about this or you know would you
consider this uh
bad yeah thank you so the uncertainty is
also useful from an active learning
perspective for the AI if it doesn't
know if something is harmful then it
might try to acquire that information in
a safe way right we don't want it to
start dissecting humans just to see
what's
inside yeah maybe small follow up what
do you do in the situation of conflict
when some people think it is good other
people think it is sorry sorry can you
speak louder yeah so uh small follow up
what do you do what this system will do
in the situation of conflict when some
people think that this is harmful you
mean disagreement yeah disagreement
between between people what AI agent
would do well so disagreement in Aion
framework is the norm it's not the
exception we've got many theories and
they're not compatible everywhere so
there there's some questions on which I
think we should go left and you think
you should go right and the like
rational way of dealing with this is to
consider all the theories weighted by
how much they are compatible with the
data so basically we just keep the
theories that are consistent with
everything we know that prunes out a lot
of garbage but there's still a lot of
theories and then we just average out
their answers if we want to take a
decision we can also if you want do
something like measure their variance
like and that is going to tell us
something about
uncertainty
so that's exactly what beijan is good
for dealing with disagreement because we
don't know what is the right answer and
we have to have what's called epistemic
humility but but what we do like in the
end it's like what does you know what's
democracy I mean ideal democracy is
somehow we come
to the the agreement that most people
agree with I mean that that the decision
that most people agree with are
something of that kind this the same
idea Asian machine learning you know is
to like social decision making like
democracy makes sense thank
you yeah that made me think but I
actually had a question about the the
part about partial theories so I fully
agree with you know the the idea that
brains or humans do not instantiate like
a theory of everything and yeah I still
don't fully grasp um yeah what do you
mean exactly by partial Theory and
especially you had think about a paper
yeah yeah so I I get the idea but for
example you say we need to be able to
evaluate partial theories I think you
have like this so what what exactly you
mean by this by how do we what what is
what we need that we don't yet have
theories so again think about scientific
papers what do we need to evaluate the
paper we don't need to look at all the
data collected by All Humans since the
beginning of time we just need to look
at some particular experimental data
that
helps you know uh answer questions about
what what what what the hypothesis are
being tested in that paper or something
right so we somehow have ways to uh
Focus
the um the match between Theory and data
to a very small part of the data space
in terms of which variables we look at
and and what we do with that
um and
I can come up with euristic to do this
but I'd like to have a mathematical
framework that naturally does that that
will
um yeah that will that will
select just the data and maybe even a
random subset of it because you probably
can't check everything so think about a
theory like you know theory of
gravitation well you're not going to
collect every single thing where gravity
comes about you want to just collect
enough to get statistical
confidence so I think we can really take
a lot of inspiration from how humans
solve the science Discovery problem in
order to uh Inspire our algorithms but I
I don't know how to do it yeah yeah I I
get that so still if I may follow up I
guess mathematically like a partial
Theory would be like a subset of
variables from the right so I have
seeing how we how can we come up with a
general way of evaluating arbitrary
subsets of of theories the combination
of the you know the combinations of
partial theories the diversity of
partial theories that we can could have
is is
huge right so the way I like to think of
building blocks for
theories is similar to the building
blocks for programs and for mathematics
it's I call them statements so you've
got a short
statement and these statements are not
independent of each other they might
refer to the same objects the same
entities same
definitions and each statement can be
true or
false and a partial theory is just going
to be a collection of these statements
which help
you explain
particular aspects of
uh some particular data points so Theory
partial theory is only helping us
understand some projection of the data
in some directions that we care about so
a theory usually in
science is about some some learned
projection of the data like some
functions of the data like let's say I
get an image but really what I care
about are okay where are the objects
where they are maybe I care only about
position and not velocity whatever right
so we we project the high dimensional
raw data into some particular variables
that are relevant to the theory and then
the theory is checking whether it's
consistent with the values that these
variables
took uh
yeah um so could you elaborate on how
gonet might help with learning a word
Model A World model yes would you see
that more um at the level of one g where
each sample might represent you know um
one piece of the word model or would you
see it at the like level of multiple
gfet that are you know trained to to
learn parts of this word model like okay
so maybe one way to think about this um
did you guys see the forward looking g-l
net no
okay no I don't have it in my
slides but but um so in a normal gonet
you have to go to the end of generating
the whole Theory before you get a reward
and that's not going to fly right that's
what I've been talking about and we've
motivated by this notion of partial
Theory and so on in fact for more than a
year I've been thinking about this we
explored a few things one of the things
was can we train a
gonet uh even if we don't get to a
terminal state
so it's just one G flet but it's going
to initially pick some aspects some
variables to say that what the Gund does
it picks a bunch of statements so let's
say a theory is a bunch of statements
that are
true the full theory is generating all
the true statements that are sufficient
to explain the data you have but that's
going to take too much time so we the
gonet might only evaluate a sub
trajectory that considers a small number
of statements and maybe something
different from the G that's more like
exploratory policy chooses
which statements are relevant to some
data we're seeing so if I see something
I might invoke just a little partial
Theory that's relevant to that for
example in the real life that's what
happens right we see a movie and you
know things come in our mind that are
relevant to what we're
seeing but so that requires to have some
sort of feed back in the uh you know
middle States and not necessarily at the
termin right so in the forward-looking
thing we assume that the reward function
isn't like a a black hole isn't a u a
sort of homogeneous thing but it can be
broken down into smaller
pieces and that's a standard assumption
in graphical models that
the um so if you remember the reward
that I had it had like fit to the data
and if you look at one piece of it which
is one data point there's going to be
[Music]
some joint
probability that involves that data and
some leing variables and we can break it
down like in graphical models into
smaller pieces corresponding to the
statistical dependencies or causal
dependencies that exist between
variables so so that's the sort of thing
we can
exploit uh so that we don't actually
need to compute the full reward but we
can get a partial reward
for
um you know some of the statements
actually are consistent with some of the
pieces of data and then you can get a
bit of reward and a bit
reward thank
you uh so um when the agent considers
different hypotheses to test how does it
go get data to test which hypothesis is
true or which one is
false well that's the standard Active
Learning problem right right it wants to
choose experiments that will provide it
with the most information and that
information in a information Theory
sense can be estimated using the model
itself because it's just some you know
some marginalization of log
probabilities that come from the model
itself so we could have another NE net
that estimates how many bits of
information we could we would get by
doing an experiment and it's very close
to the way we're doing now Active
Learning with
gonets and then um that would drive
which experiment would be
conducted like it would be a reward for
deciding what to
do um and then the G the gonet would
sample experiments that have a high
Information
Gain also like to what extent do you see
like methods from goal conditional
reinforcement learning from what goal
condition reinfor enforcement learning
goal condition right right right help in
acquiring this data
actively
um yeah so it it's
um it's a good question
um um I think that
um there are many cases where if we want
to do this divide and conquer idea that
I was talking about we we want to do
something like goal
conditioning
um think about how you prove a theorem
right we you you might not want to
generate directly foolproof but you
first create some sub goals which are
like lemas that are easier to prove
right
um so so I think I think the goal
conditioning literature from RL could be
a useful thing in U in our toolbox for
sure also one broad question like uh in
the plan that you presented overall I
did not see a lot of RL like why is it
so no I I repeated many times that I
think we can take inspiration from a lot
of exis existing RL right but we're not
trying to solve the standard RL
problems we're trying to solve a
different problem which would be good
for scientific discovery would be good
for
safety
um
um and yeah uh uh it's not trying to
maximize reward it's trying to
understand how the world works and then
use that in in a way that takes
uncertainty into
account yeah I was more thinking along
the lines of whether the agents that you
presented have agency in them or is it
just like so I the the AI scientist
doesn't have agency but it needs to
model agency because if it's modeling
the effective actions of some
agent uh I mean it needs to be able to
to do that in order to predict what's
going to happen if something bad is
going to happen or what so you you do
need that AI scientist to understand
agents but it doesn't need itself to be
an
agent yeah frontal cortex right thank
youhua Emanuel maybe last question uh
unfortunately I'm just hijacking the mic
the mic um oh okay yeah thank you uh
thanks to all the speakers thanks to all
the organizers it was uh took a long
time to organize all of this and it was
very fun so also thanks everyone for
coming